billy enfin dans les bras de son maître
celle épilogue de six jours de
recherches intensives il ait pas besoin
de connaître la langue de shakespeare
pour comprendre l'émotion de son
propriétaire anglais fantastique
et pourtant les choses étaient bien mal
engagée mercredi dernier billy un
terrier de 13 ans à la très mauvaise
idée de chasser les ragondins dans un
aqueduc façon sous le canal il y reste
coincé et malgré ses aboiements
impossible de le localiser les pompiers
interviendront un temps mais c'est
surtout la mobilisation des bénévoles
qui va finir par payer et la mise en
place d'une nouvelle stratégie
hier soir aux relevés de caméras on a on
a détecté des galeries de ragondins à
six mètres de l'entrée l'endroit de le
point de chute était à peu près sur la
berge
on a tenté le tout pour le tout jute le
vn et plus auront baissé le niveau de 20
cm la sortie on avait une sortie
derrière juste le
le amas de terre là on a un petit
bonheur la chance on a creusé et on est
tombé dessus la baisse du niveau du
canal semble t'il dégager les entrées
des éventuels terrier est permis de
localiser le chien la suite vous la
connaissez
après ses aventures billy a été
transporté chez le vétérinaire
il est en bonne santé et devrait
retrouver rapidement son panier